oh i'm close to my peak
okay i'll play one more i was gonna wrap
things up but i'll play one more
we'll try and hit a peak today
oh i like that title from 41 mat 14.
i'm going to copy that
when it comes to
making youtube videos
the title is really important
[Music]
because it incentivizes people to click
on the video
so for that previous game i played this
stream
[Music]
uh i like this title
[Music]
oh no my queen oh yes my ponziani
okay
i'm playing lucidchus
normally if i wanna like be aggressive
when quickly i'll play e5
but in this game i'm gonna stick with my
main repertoire and play e6
and sometimes a move order can be tricky
in these lines
yeah i have a choice here um
i could take
or play d4 i think i'll play d4
this is another line i haven't looked at
in a while but i have some knowledge
about
it's actually what i prepared for sagar
shah
in our speeches
match
um we're going into a reverse bononi
and this is one of the more principled
ways of
playing this opening
but it will get dynamic
white has potential to go for like
reverse binko gambit
i think more typical is take take in d3
my goal is to keep some time advantage
this game
[Music]
okay so knight a3
uh yeah this is very typical to try and
attack the pawn
i'm considering bishop c5 but i think i
want to play bishop e7
i definitely don't want to take the
knight because i give white the bishop
pair
and the reason to play bishop b7 is so
that my knight can potentially go to c5
later
although there's knight c2
knight c2 e5 rookie one
i think that's okay
yeah so the goal is to uh to play knight
d7 get an e5
maybe even get a structure with f6 win
connect four
and then put the knight on c5
and then also play a5 there's a lot of
things i want to do in this position
i think i'll start with this move
depriving the bishop of
trading itself off
yeah this is a key maneuver
sometimes it backfires and
the timing's wrong but
i think here it's okay
b4 is still discouraged
i have a3i of a5 hey it's irene what's
up irene
oh good morning to irene
just after 9 a.m in indonesia
i'm trying to stay super focused this
game because
my peak rating is on the line
also for those just joining this is
probably going to be my last game of the
stream
um
because restaurants are closing soon
and i would like to avoid starving
okay so preventing b4
irene you need to stream soon
because when i give you a shout out
it
links to a more empty twitch channel
i guess i should include your youtube
channel too in the shout out
okay white really wants to play b4
so i could play a4 which is kind of
typical
i'm also considering knight c5
which would kind of go into a weird line
like take shakes takes takes
i fork things in the end
and then i potentially fork more things
because a4 allows this weird knight
before move
i'm just trying to make sense of this
line
i might be
missing rook d5
and then takes
but that doesn't work because it takes
takes
i mean a4 knight b4 f6 we trade
there's this move
i think i'll start with a4
yeah i'm probably like
probably for the rest of this game i'm
not going to look at chats
i don't want to be influenced by move
suggestions
i'll just try and stay super focused
i'll try and have a
high quality finish to the stream
yeah f6 takes takes
uh knight goes here i have like some
queen move
tickle the pawn
taking i think only helps whites
and white's getting kind of this benoni
compensation
but i still have potential for my knight
coming to c5
there's actually a line
where i sack a pawn
i'm looking at uh takes takes
knight h4 knight c5 bishop c6 bishop b7
right if i can force betray the bishops
and then return the knight never mind
okay so that of course is a move
now i just want to play this and be
happy
if takes takes bishop here i take take
and then knight b3
and then win the pawn
also pressuring d3 here
wow
and this is similar to the other line
[Music]
i guess with this one
[Music]
let's calculate takes takes knight b3
it feels a little bit awkward
uh bishop e6
i can play bishop d62
[Music]
play this
that way i don't even give white the
option of trading off the knight
and even though the knight looks strong
it doesn't have too many squares to go
to it's actually completely restricted
it's like an octopus
in a cage
now i just want to play bishop e6
or maybe even bishop f5
or this move
should also be moving a bit quicker here
if i play knight b3
king h8 so i don't know what to do
i feel like the king's safer here
if there's about five there's rook t1
bishop five might also just give white
tempo after knight h5 eventually
it's a very tense position
one benefit to king h8 is when i play
this the bishop can actually drop back
and just get out the way
thank you michael hoffman oh michael
gifting to irene
yeah yeah i'm not looking at chat so if
people wanna like discuss variations
um
[Music]
i'm
gonna be focusing
just the position in front of me
now time-wise it's still okay
i mean white has some choices to make
too
if there's a basic improving move
i have some basic improving moves
okay h4 really makes me want to play
this move
yeah the reason why i didn't play bishop
g4 earlier is h3
the pawns can't move backwards
now maybe there's some idea to maneuver
the queen
although i'd have to watch out queen
eight there's takes takes and fork
we can see two
out of the pin
i have knight b3
and then do some trades
it's really easy to get forked like here
here there's this
my queen doesn't really have squares to
move to
i wonder if i can play rook a6
the idea is just to avoid some forks
sometimes the rook can be useful in the
six rank
i really just want to play this and not
get forked
knight d2 interesting
man this position is so tense today's
stream title is our slash oddly
satisfying material
i forget what i titled the stream but i
don't have time to think about what i
told it because i
need to focus on this position
uh
there's f oh f5 is interesting
[Music]
oh i titled it raising something reading
rosen's rating
i forgot my name for a moment okay
should i play f5
f3 bishop back let's play f5
and it's kind of risky like we can e5 a
little bit but
e5 is defended
i want to play
actually do i want to play this
super double edged
it would target the king side but give
away the e4 square
i might want to play e4
even though white has too many attackers
on e4
be an interesting gambit
g5 may be possible
okay so now the bishop's blocked f4
might be coming
okay f4 i take
i'm not sure if f3 actually helped white
there
b3
i don't have to take i could take
there's a prospect of
so many prospects
there's takes takes takes
trade everything
i kind of want to play bishop f7
because there's a case after takes takes
we trade on d6
then the knight can hop into c3
especially if i include bishop d5
that move i forgot about because b4 is
coming
oh no i kind of blundered
i'm just losing material now
or am i
i am
but let's treat it as a gambit
yeah oh that's so sad
i take this
it takes and then
now i think i just moved back
okay we have to treat every blunder as a
gambit
unfortunately the knight's not trapped
as a square
um
if i not lose material
let me see seven
maybe six maybe
another move i want to play
if i'm down a piece here
oh white's tactics kind of worked out
funny line f4 e4 takes and then i win a
queen
all right my goal is to meet this with
this and just blockade with my
queen and hope it's okay
i still might want to play this move
takes takes
interesting
[Music]
maybe could have considered that right
away
thank you
g tarda
tardad
oh guitar dad
thanks for subbing
for the first time
white's still a bit restricted with the
pieces especially the minor pieces
so i might not be in so much of a rush
i really want to play this move
i don't think it works so
[Music]
i'll start with this
trying to increase pressure
and white's tempting me
not giving in
uh i double up i lose a4
f4 no
not what i want
actually i want to play g5 now
my new plan
here i think i can take
i mean c6 is going to be lost but
at least there's some
stuff happening
yeah white may have missed the
in-between move
in betweener
if here i play this
feels like there's compensation now
queen is still stable here
oh i'm also threatening h4
and pawn survives on g3 i mean my rook
might be target
but okay takes i might even take
33 seconds oh takes takes takes and then
queen f2 is winning
oh that's a mean move
of this move
or this move
i'll be this move
play on instinct now
probably want to play this soon
making h7
[Music]
a3 is now
hanging king is reasonably safe also
this idea
but that would allow queenie queen a4
also this idea
i want to play rookie 7.
i mean before may be coming
okay
between f4
okay getting what i want kind of
wow look at my pawns
they're so beautiful kind of
my time
i have a pawn diamond
let's advance a diamond
diamonds are forever right
diamonds are forever let's go
oh that's a fun game
actually my pawn diamond was very
short-lived
but it led to meat
okay
oh it was a
intense time scramble
hey i got to my peak
got to 26.50 good game lucidcharts
definitely i definitely got outplayed
there but uh
this was
tricky enough to survive
oh lucidchus live in the chat yeah
thanks for the game
um
very tricky play in the middle game like
super super tense position
uh
[Music]
oh engine really liked my position
so apparently i missed some tactical
sequence
after b3
there are a lot of different ways to
capture stuff
so why is knight before so winning
wow
e4
how am i supposed to find e4
what does this move even
i leave my knight hanging
and takes and then
i don't even take
okay i take a pawn with a bishop
oh
that's hard to see
i guess this kind of makes sense that's
so hard to see though
e4 right away
isn't as strong as bishop takes so i
have to remove the bishop play e4 takes
sack the knight and then go in for the
kill
that's hard to
find oh thank you vashtiya's gifting to
lucidchess live
yeah this is clever though because uh
i played what i thought was an okay move
after so bishop f7
evaluation went from
minus 5 in my favor a plus 2 in white's
favor
because of the sequence takes takes and
then after b4 i'm
i'm losing one of these things
um
yeah i was considering takes
but then
after it takes i'm still losing a thing
[Music]
so
yeah i thought this gave me the best
chances uh
[Music]
at least the game kept going
and then
i mean the position got really wacky
especially after the queen trade
yeah this is crazy because white's up a
piece but i have like four pawns
ready to storm down
and time scramble situation i think it
was a bit easier to play for black
oh i missed rookie one
rookie one's force mate how is the force
mates
f3
oh f3 makes sense
mike can give some fight checks or h3
this is a funny line though king g1 h3
a pawns are so powerful
[Music]
rook a1 and f3
and then here and then here and then
here and then here
and then it's it's a nice diamond white
queens
or knights and then mate
alternative ending to the story